une nouvelle rame a fait son apparition
à andrésy cette annexe au relais
d'assistants maternels déjà existant est
effective depuis le 6 novembre
elle prend place au complexe sportif
stéphane diagana le bâtiment existait il
y avait un créneau disponible le
matériel existait puisqu'il était
précédemment au gymnase louise weiss
pourquoi ne pas ouvrir ici une annexe ça
ne coûtait pas d'argent le personnel
était déjà présent donc autant faire et
vous voyez c'est ça semble très apprécié
objectif de cette annexe située à quatre
kilomètres du relais principal proposer
un accueil de proximité pour les
assistantes maternelles du quartier qui
traversait la ville à pied avec des
enfants en bas âge fallait prendre la
voiture
bon c'était compliqué surtout quand on a
trois ou quatre enfants et donc on avait
fait cette demande depuis déjà assez
longtemps donc le fait que ce soit
exaucé c'est super pour y aller c'était
pas évident que là c'est vrai que c'est
tout près on peut y aller à pied et
c'est vrai que c'est bien pour nous et
stoppa qui sont de ce côté là au
programme des activités ludiques dans un
esprit de motricité libre grâce à du
matériel mis à disposition avec les
enfants vient ici peuvent s'amuser
vraiment dans une structure qui est
adapté et ses claques parce qu'ils sont
ils sont plusieurs et puis ils font ce
qu'ils veulent
un créneau horaire est dédié à cette
nouvelle annexe le vendredi matin de 9
heures à 10 heures vendredi dernier
cette assistante maternelle et une
vingtaine d'enfants ont pu en profiter